students who witnessed the deadly school
shooting are set to confront Florida
legislators today who just voted to put
off any action on guns buses carrying
dozens of students from Stone and
Douglas high arrived and telling how to
see last night they will meet lawmakers
from both parties this morning
other students will hold the first
organized rally of what they call the
never again movement to nationwide
rallies are scheduled for next month
the teenagers arrived after Florida's
House of Representatives rejected a
motion to debate a bill banning assault
weapons Adriana Diaz traveled from
parkland Florida to the state capitol
with the students she's with us now from
Tallahassee
Adriana good morning good morning the
students we spoke to this morning told
us they barely got any sleep last night
their chaperones said they were up all
night talking right now they're having
breakfast and from here they will go to
the State Capitol where they will meet
with lawmakers who they say need to get
tougher on gun laws three charter bus is
filled with about a hundred students
from Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High
School arrived in Tallahassee just
before 10:00 Tuesday night Democratic
state senator Lauren books as lawmakers
from both parties are ready to hear the
students demands for change they are
resilient they are strong and they are
going to be the change that is going to
happen here in Florida a new nationwide
poll found that 75% of Americans believe
Congress isn't doing enough to reduce
gun violence but on Tuesday a state
motion to consider a bill proposing a
ban on assault rifles was struck down 36
to 71 some state legislators argue gun
ownership is a constitutional right and
the focus should be on school security
and better mental health screenings
Stoneman Douglas junior sherrilyn
Corolla was watching the vote
I'm someone with an assault rifle here
in Florida is good to be on them it's
going to be it's going to be their
siblings Julia and Daniel heard the news
on the bus to Tallahassee but there's a
strong force of all of us and I know
that we would not travel this far just
to get nothing done new photos from
inside their clothes school show empty
classrooms and textbooks still open on
desks lorena sanabria was there during
the shooting a horror she wants
lawmakers to understand want you to
experience a school shooting I want you
to be there I want you to hear the gun
shots I want you to listen I want you to
read the messages that one of your
friends has been shot and I want you to
process that the students hope to
convince lawmakers to pass new
legislation like stricter background
checks and a ban on assault weapons
State Senator book told us that this
whole trip was passed and funded was
actually funded by state legislators on
both sides of the aisle out of their own
pockets Gale all right thank you very
much Adriana you know it's so inspiring
to hear young people lobby legislators
knowing that their voices can be heard
that they can make a difference and also
how to try and present the pain that
they felt to people who were not there
and I think people are saying or that's
the difference between this and Sandy
Hook these kids were there they can
speak up and they want you to know and
it reminds many people of the civil
rights movement back in the day those
young people spoke up and they made a
difference back in to change the civil
rights in this country and many people
believe that could happen again this
time we will see